le ciel s'était rapproché jusqu'à
recouvrir partiellement la coupole de la
basilique Saint-Pierre au centre de la
place le cercueil de bois de Joseph
Ratzinger a été déposé sous les
applaudissements nourri des fidèles qui
s'étaient déplacés pour assister au
funérailles du papeet Mérite présidé par
le pape François la cérémonie s'est
ouverte dans le recueillement par la
récitation du
[Musique]
chapeleto dans son homélie François est
parti des dernières paroles du Christ
sur la croix père entre tes mains je
remets mon esprit
au fil des brefs paroles qui la
prononçait le pape à des pins Benoît XV
comme un reflet du Christ mais aussi
comme un pasteur pour qui il a exprimé
un dernier
souhaitait
la nuit de l'époux que ta joie soit
parfaite en entendant sa voix
définitivement et pour toujours
après une dernière bénédiction du Pape
François c'est une fois de plus sous les
applaudissements soutenus que le
cercueil de Benoît XV a quitté le parvis
de la place Saint-Pierre vers la
basilique entourée de proches qui l'ont
accompagné jusqu'à la fin c'est loin des
caméras que les cérémonies se sont
poursuivies le cercueil du pape Benoît
XVI a été entouré de zinc comme levé la
tradition puis déposer dans une boîte de
bois avant d'être inhumée dans une
crypte dans les grottes de Saint-Pierre
aux côtés d'autres papes il repose pour
l'éternité Benoît Henry est ressorti ému
des cérémonies j'ai toujours émouvant
parce que c'est un au revoir à quelqu'un
qui nous est cher et
c'est émouvant parce que parce que voilà
on est tous là pour lui dire au revoir
et puis forcément bah ça fait prendre de
la hauteur sur sur la vie sur l'église
beaucoup de ceux qui ont fait comme lui
le voyage pour rendre une multimommage
ou par pratinger était comme lui
originaire de Bavière un esprit brillant
et croyant et c'était
le chemin direct et les chemins
merci PAP Benoît pouvait-on lire sur
certaines banderoles mais comme beaucoup
des fidèles endeuillés Marie reconnaît
avoir mal connu Benoît XVI pour elle
Jean-Paul II restera toujours le pape
mais en fait Jean-Paul II ça a été toute
mon enfance c'est ma vie donc moi j'ai
pris souvenir de lui c'est en quelque
sorte un peu plus à la fonction qu'à
l'homme qu'on rendait hommage
aujourd'hui
ici Marie-Eve Bédard Radio-Canada au
Vatican